[Music]
take that out
I like it get that out of there man
Ryan we got 10 minutes left 10 minutes
left Ryan's got a head cold he's about
to have a hot ass do you want me to do
it don't ask me you volunteered yourself
I volunteered you and then you I said
why does it have to be me and then you
said I'll do it I'll do it with you
no
do two I don't want to do it
why don't you do I don't want to let's
take a little nibble
no I I
you know normally I'd be down but I do
have a lot of [__] to take care of and
it would [__] my day up just take a
little too
no because it's gonna I'm gonna be in
pain I'm gonna have to [__]
go ahead Ryan all right you don't have
to
yeah
we know we're good tomorrow we gotta
banking okay Ryan stop no no tomorrow
we're gonna stop bullshitting Ryan let's
go eat that are you serious I mean just
take just take a bite you don't have to
do that you don't have to do that you
don't you can do a quarter of a quarter
chip challenge you guys are going to
somebody has to not really but yeah it's
like those we kind of need the the clip
for the you know next or this week on
the bonus episode we need that sort of
what's that what's that movie thing
um somebody's Gun
there's a gun in the movie you have to
oh yeah something's law where you have
if a gun is visible what is it
chekhov's gun yeah what's the law if you
present a a gun in a movie in a movie
the audience wants someone to shoot it
no you should use it
I used to do improv in New York City and
we had when I was first learning we did
a scene where we were always talking
about like [__] like oh everybody's
got a [__] you know it's a stupid scene
and we didn't [__] the entire time and
so we got off stage and our coach was
like if you're gonna talk about [__]
on stage you have to [__] on stage so
now you think the audience expects you
to then yeah because you talk about it
the entire time and then you just leave
them and they're like well that was good
oh dumb okay
all right [__]
just take a bite don't you have to do
the whole thing or the record well when
you watch people do the challenge they
put the whole thing in their mouth [__]
this is gonna [__] me up guys let's take
a little nibble I have a head cold for
the record this will help how are you
with space
yeah don't do the whole thing fine okay
[Music]
[__] guys
oh this is like really bad
I feel really bad now
it's like immediate [__]
I feel so bad I feel really bad yeah me
too I'm scared to swallow it don't
swallow it just it's all in my mouth
just spit it out but but like let me see
that
I feel like you ate out an alien dude
that was so bad
oh God now I swallowed it that's really
bad yeah Obi can I get some water
you want ranch oh dude you should drink
the corn soda that is
Oh no I got hiccups
that is so bad oh no
[Music]
I feel for you yeah can we get some
beatbox
for Ryan
well look you can get some pumpkin pie
box please
oh my God one of you guys should do that
[Music]
about
you know Cody yeah dude I'm really
convinced
no I'm really convinced dude
she doesn't water make it worse he needs
some milk yeah he needs some milk
do we have yogurt they're getting worse
yeah it is
getting better Cody will do it say it's
totally fine
all good dude it's so good
that's worse than the hot one [__]
I felt so bad dude I'm sorry
I want it to be over for you awesome
I'm lactose intolerant though oh God
Swig it Swig it yeah
it's getting better now right
it's like
don't swallow it okay I have to it's so
are you gonna be like dire you're gonna
have the hottest diarrhea now
yo that's
so bad
oh it's gonna last for a long time too I
can tell
it's just
crackers oh no no come on now
here I have some of these
no no those are so bad dude have some of
this pickle it'll help you feel better I
don't like yeah have that Warhead pickle
have some of the sour pickle
oh yeah
it like minimizes for a second when you
drink the milk and then it like comes
back in like full force I feel like
you're dealing with it pretty well I
feel like I'm dying right now really
yeah
I no I mean it sucks but you know it's
getting better it's yeah it's but it's
so bad go ahead Connie
I can't dude not after watching that
I will another Tuesday when I don't have
any plans afterwards just a little bit
would oh God it doesn't go away he's
about to finish the milk
yeah there's not going to be much milk
left don't do it Noel
smell
hurts my nose just smelling it we'll
push it on another bonus episode
when we have a full gallon of milk for
you I will absolutely do it at one point
man it's like it's like it's like I have
to expect it though
it's like cake yeah don't touch it
because then you're gonna touch your
eyes
don't that even that much Noel no no
you're crazy
you gotta wash your hands this looks
like beef jerky man
whoa is it getting better
it's like that my tongue is on fire and
the milk helps it for a little bit no
thank you
lick it dude that's fizzy you're
drinking the what which one is that
anything buffalo wings that's gonna make
it worse
water doesn't help you want the ranch
one because maybe that'll distract you
from the pain I don't like Ranch oh dude
oh my God so you distracted you right
but now my mouth is on fire and I feel
like I want to puke I promise I will do
it another day get another one of these
and I will do it
all right I feel like it's going down
now so that's about how long it lasts
however he took just a bite of the tree
he didn't mean the whole thing no but
he's gonna feel it the rest of the day
oh
yeah all right well that's it for the
bonus
thank you for doing that though thank
you everyone for you guys anything for
you guys
um gotta get us some more milk well we
will do this
the one chip challenge and at least
someone did it today so we didn't we did
Shop's gun or whatever it's called we
did shakanov's gun
has been we jacked we did jack off
jacking off's gun yeah yeah we should on
stage Shot Golf
I saw a tweet that was like I hate it
makes me so mad that jacking off in
German is meat and schlapping
thanks for joining us guys see you next
time